please welcome Academy Award nominee
stave an Academy Award winner Phil
Collins
all night we've been in the best musical
hands possible thanks to our conductor
Harold wheeler and a great group of
talented musicians
to capture the essence style in the mood
of a movie and then translate that into
music is the genius of the film composer
and the nominees for the best original
score' are big fish by Danny Elfman cold
mountain by Garfield yarn
finding Nemo Thomas knew House of Sand
and Fog by James Horner
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King by Howard show
and the Oscar goes to Howard Shore not
of the Rings Return of the King
including his nomination this year for
original song this is how it sure is
third nomination and second Academy
Award
Oh incredible
just breathe the better um maybe thanks
to the Academy I'd like to share this
Oscar with all the amazing musicians and
great vocal artists who played on this
piece a special note to Annie Lennox
Renee Fleming Sir James Galway and el
maestro I was incredibly inspired by
tokens great work Peter Jackson's a
visionary filmmaking great writing of
Fran Walsh Philippa boyens Elizabeth my
darling I love you I thank you for your
love and support may for your wonderful
encouragement all the people who have
helped us through this making of these
films Bob and Michael Paul and Laurie
Barry Osborne Rick porous Sam and Mike
Ronald jean-jacques I thank you Robbie
Kearns Marc Wilshere and of course
Steven Einhorn thanks so much thank you
Academy thank you
please welcome Julianne Moore and Pierce
Brosnan